with every new discovery the universe
keeps challenging us with all today's
technological advancements there still
remain a considerable number of blanks
in the macro cosmos unexplored physical
phenomena taking place and the remotest
corners of our galaxy are able to both
horrify and amaze researchers of deep
space and today we will tell you about
one of these things the most powerful
magnets in the universe with a
staggeringly high level of radiation
magnet ours
mankind has come across some extremely
powerful radiation that reached us from
deep space several times in the last 50
years but as often is the case with
space discoveries the source was slow in
being detected by astrophysicists 1979
three us Vela satellites monitoring
nuclear tests on the earth detected an
unusual gamma-ray flare 1992
astrophysicists assumed that there was a
celestial object out there not known to
science with a huge electromagnetic
radiation coefficient 1998 a gamma-ray
flare in the constellation Aquila a
number of measuring devices registered
and unaccountable anomaly with its
source located tens of thousands of
light-years away from us 2004 all
telescopes in the world were for a short
time dazzled less than a second later
every cubic centimeter in the solar
system experienced a wave of gamma ray
radiation the most massive bursts in the
entire history of observations and today
we're closer than ever to finally
putting our finger on the nature of this
discovery a magnetar is a neutron star
with an exceptionally powerful magnetic
field of about 10 to the power of 13
Tesla's which in essence is trillions of
times that of the electromagnetic
radiation on the earth it is also one of
the rarest and really most dangerous
phenomena ever encountered by mankind
when a supermassive stars on the point
of dying as supernova occurs among the
multiple scenarios of what may take
place after that only one may leap to
the star becoming a magnetar after the
supernova many of you would have heard
about the Russian Roulettes at least
once in your lives according to the
rules only one cartridge is put in the
revolver cylinder the chance of
producing a shot after you have spun the
cylinder is rather small however when it
does happen the consequences are truly
mind-blowing
be it as it may scientists are still at
odds over what exactly this scenario
would look like according to the first
theory it's the inner energy of the star
and its rotational energy that
influenced the formation of a magnetar
if a neutron stars formed at the time of
fast rotation the inner energy of this
star as well as its rotational energy
which is of great significance in the
first several seconds all create a
powerful magnetic field this process is
known to science as a dynamo mechanism
but there is another theory as well
after the accretion process the magnetar
may be able to receive energy from
another star scientists have discovered
a magnetar which is on an escape
trajectory from our galaxy most moving
stars we know set off on their
trajectories as a result of supernovae
in binary systems this means that the
accretion process takes place between
the two stars with a common mass center
in a binary system matter from one star
gradually flows to the other in this
case this is the source of energy for a
potential magnetar
something similar happens with a
basketball spinning around the edge of
the basket sooner or later it is going
to fall but it's the spinning process
that pre defines the direction of the
fall magnet hours spin on their rack
sees extremely fast with a speed varying
between tens and thousands of times per
second at the same time their dimensions
are record small as a rule the diameter
of a magnetar reaches a measly 20 to 30
kilometers just to compare the diameter
of the moon equals 3000 474 kilometers
that is about 173 times that of the
average magnetar the mass however is a
completely different matter a magnetar
with the diameter of 15 kilometers will
be significantly heavier than our Sun
despite the dimensions it is at
staggeringly powerful density of the
interior that is the reason for its high
magnetic radiation for instance 1e 104
8.1 - 5 937 is an anomalous x-ray pulse
are located 9,000 light-years away in
the constellation Carina the star the
magnet I evolved from had the mass 30 to
40 times that of our Sun the matter in
these stars is dense to such a point
that a fountain pen cap would weigh
billions of tons and a human would be
torn to bits within a matter of seconds
after landing on the Stars surface
several years ago astronomers from NASA
managed to register phenomenon which
came to be known as a starquake thanks
to the Fermi gamma-ray Space Telescope
scientists received data about intense
x-ray bursts their source was magnetar
as grj 155 o minus 5 4 1 8 the magnetic
field of this star is so powerful that
from time to time its crust bursts with
vast amounts of energy released through
the crack such starquakes are the source
of pulsed electric current in theory if
a magnet are of this kind at its most
active were to find itself within the
boundaries of the solar system we
wouldn't as much as notice the threat as
the ozone layer of the earth together
with all organic life forms would be
wiped off within a matter of a few
hundreds of a second fortunately however
the magnet are closest to us is a safe
enough distance away a magnetized hard
to approach not only due to the
gravitational properties of its core and
energy flares at the time of a starquake
when a magnetized in its stable
condition its magnetic field is able to
mess with electric devices hundreds of
thousands of kilometers away and within
the radius of a thousand kilometers any
object would be reduced to atoms in
order to systematize the difference in
their radiation scientists decided to
divide magnet ARS into two variety
is by using abbreviations rather than
the full names you will see these in any
astronomical catalogue SGR soft gamma
repeater and day XP anomalous x-ray
pulsar in essence
SGI and day XP are different phases in
the life of one and the same object
according to scientists a magnetar
exists as an SG our pulsar for the first
10,000 years that is it's a pulsar
visible and regular light and repeatedly
emitting bursts of soft gamma rays as
time goes by it exhausts its properties
and recedes into the invisible spectrum
when it can be seen to us only in the
x-ray range as an ax P according to
different sources today among billions
of neutron stars the number of known
potential magnetized ranges from 30 to
150 there are about 12 of them in the
Milky Way with a closest onto the name
182 to 59 plus 586 being about 4 kilo
parsecs or 13,000 light years away from
our earth the magnetized a soft gamma
repeater and if a starquake were to take
place on its surface it would affect us
only by some slight changes in the top
layers of the ionosphere due to their
small dimensions and remoteness relative
to the earth magnet ours cannot be
observed through regular amateur
telescopes the method of infrared or
x-ray scanning of the sky is usually
employed to observe them nevertheless
thanks to their active magnetic field
emission and radiation these stars are
much easier to detect with the use of
various instruments this is exactly what
took place several years ago in 2013
astronomers claimed to have discovered a
magnetar in close proximity to a
supermassive black hole right in the
middle of the Milky Way the star was
detected thanks to several orbital
telescopes including the Chandra x-ray
Space Observatory
SGR 1 7 4 5 - 2 9 wo is only 0.3
light-years away from the edge of the
black hole and to date it remains the
only neutron star to have been
discovered in close proximity to an
object of this scale SGR one 745 - 2 9
double O has been observed by scientists
ever since its discovery several years
ago the level of its x-ray radiation was
proclaimed to be significantly lower
than that of the stars of this category
then use prompted numerous debates can
these changes have been caused by the
black hole and the stars environs after
two years of observing as gr 1 7 4 5 - 2
9 double-o astrophysicists came to the
conclusion that all things considered
the distance of 0.3 light-years isn't
sufficient for any interaction in the
magnetic or gravitational field to take
place between the black hole and the
magnetar after all the reason is likely
to lurk elsewhere a magnetized lifespan
is quite short just about a million
years and it's quite natural for its
magnetic field to gradually die down
throughout the Stars existence some
scientists assume that these processes
may be the reason for the change of the
Stars status in this case magnet ours
can switch their category flare up more
frequently or less often deplete the
stock of the matter and thus go from the
category of SGR to the category of axp
in its autumn years a form a magnetar
that managed to survive the dissipation
of its magnetic field may even become
quite a different kind of star namely a
thermally emitting neutron star so far
just about seven objects of the kind and
known to science for their number this
group has been dubbed the Magnificent
Seven and each of them may once have
been one of the most dangerous objects
of deep space
but in order to establish that it will
take us long years further technological
advancements and dedicated people
willing to devote their lives to
searching for solutions to the most
dangerous and incredible mysteries of
the universe